la condition de la femme a beaucoup
évolué ces temps derniers cela est dû à
l'action récente des mouvements
féministes bien sûr mais il ne faut pas
oublier que rien n'aurait été possible
sans les féministe de la première heure
les au début du siècle qui est sûr et
avant la dernière guerre par exemple ce
soir je crois que c'est l'occasion de
rappeler leurs actions france dispose du
derby d'epsom en 1913 ou la suffragette
emilie davidson trouvent la mort en se
jetant sous les sabots du cheval du roi
aux manifestations féministes
d'aujourd'hui quelque soixante dix
années de luxe se seront écoulés mais il
faut le savoir
c'est dans la france 2 779 avec l'abbé
poulains de la barre que s'est éveillée
la notion d'égalité des sexes à paris
dans le 5e arrondissement
les documents de la bibliothèque
marguerite durand une ardente
journaliste suffragettes de 1900 montre
à l'évidence combien l'histoire de
l'émancipation féminine se présente
comme une série de rendez vous manqué
avec l'histoire tout court
tout se passera sur le mode de 1789
jusqu'à l'obtention du droit de vote
dans les bouleversements de violence
national ou international
les femmes jouent un rôle politique puis
une fois les société apaisée sont
renvoyés à leurs fourneaux berceau dodo
dès 1830 avant engels et les féministes
de mai 68
flora tristan avait trouvé la formule
choc la femme est la prolétaire de
l'homme en 1848
les saint simonienne annonçait toutes
les revendications féministes du temps
extraordinaire liberté de ton et
vitalité de la presse des femmes à cette
époque avec la commune en 1871
le mouvement féministe se fait absorber
par le mouvement ouvrier et se font dans
les revendications de l'ensemble des
travailleurs
il entrera en sommeil pour de longues
années
il faudra attendre le début du siècle
après de violentes manifestations aux
usa en grande bretagne pour que les
suffragettes anglo saxon finisse après
maintes grève de la faim par arracher le
droit de vote
souvent brocardé la reine victoria elle
même ne les aimais pas elles obtiennent
leurs droits politiques en 1918
les actions suffrages east française
s'engage dès 1900 et se poursuivront
avec pétition appelle candidature durant
des années avant la seconde guerre
mondiale louise weiss sera la figure de
proue de ce combat difficile
les plus convaincus des républicains
redoutant l'influencent du clergé sur
les électrices c'est par l'écriture avec
simone de beauvoir son célèbre on ne
naît pas femme on le devient
betty frier dan puis kate milette et
pour ne citer que ces contemporaine
aujourd'hui benoîte groult que s'ouvrira
une réflexion féministe nouvelle adrian
volant bonjour marie pierre boucher
michel lavit appris merci
vous êtes des auxiliaires précieuse pour
défendre la cause des chiffres à ce
départ
je menais laborderie place pour défendre
la cause des femmes
merci en 45 la france aura été le 36e
états du monde a accordé le droit
politique femmes si les actions des
suffragettes venez apparaissent
aujourd'hui quelque peu dérisoire
elle reste cependant exemplaires pour la
femme de 1982 en témoignant du même
désir de voir disparaître un sexisme qui
au cours de l'histoire est encore dans
maints pays s'est identifié un racisme
de poids racisme qu'une célébration du 8
mars journée des femmes curieusement
emprunté aux pays de l'est ne suffit
peut-être pas en elles-mêmes à éliminer
totalement des mentalités dans
l'actualité politique français